c'est la fin d'une époque pour le
Canadien de Montréal Marc Bergevin
quitte l'organisation avec un bilan
mitigé un peu moins d'une décennie après
son embauche depuis quelques semaines le
divorce semblait inéluctable le
propriétaire Jeff Monson avait d'abord
décidé de le laisser couler la dernière
année de son contrat puis on apprenait
samedi soir quel processus d'embauche de
son successeur avait commencé Bergevin
part au moment où l'équipe connais le
pire début de 16 ans de 612 ans
d'histoire par communiquer il a 10 ans
elle est la tête haute il a également
tenu à remercier les partisans
Schubert je vais le Tricolore a atteint
les plus hauts sommets mais aussi
patauger dans les bas-fonds la présence
en finale de la Coupe Stanley l'été
dernier de mœurs en plus au fait d'armes
les derniers mois un peu de fois et tu
es pénible avec le départ de Philippe
Danault la retraite forcée de chez web
et les problèmes de consommation de
Queyries Price à peine 144 jours après
avoir raté la finale l'équipe couper au
29e rang de la Ligue nationale le
Canadien aussi raté les séries 4 fois la
dernière saison de tout son règne
l'échange de piqué Subban en retour de
chez weather leur a marqué au fer rouge
ces dernières années son équipe de
recrutement amateur a été largement
critiquer pour ces mauvaises décisions
le gourou je rappelle
dimanche
vers l'avenir de nouveau directeur
général et commencer et celui-ci devra
parler français assurer Jeff Monson le
propriétaire a engagé lancer DJ les
Rangers de New York pour l'aider dans sa
tâche les noms de Patrick Roy de Mathieu
d'arche et de Martin circule déjà après
des mois à avoir éviter les médias j'ai
commencé à le silence le lundi matin ici
Alexandre gascon Radio-Canada à Montréal